change lives she's gotta be the lives
change organizations guy BST
organization until I saw somebody change
the world Vikram it's a truly a pleasure
to be here with you today um I don't
think I've told you this yet but for a
period of time in my life I had my
student loan my home mortgage my
checking account my savings account and
my credit card all with city so in my
mind you are too big to fail hmm you've
been paying on time so we've um
had a chance to interact a couple times
on Capitol Hill that's right and when I
was on Capitol Hill oftentimes senators
and even the White House would say what
does Vikram think so I thought a good
place to start would be to get your view
of the state of play of the global
financial markets share with us what is
top of mind for you when you think of
the global economy yeah I think that's a
good place to start Derrick it's good to
see all of you so pleasure to be with
you I saw Derek first when he was in
senator McConnell's office and this was
during the depths of the crisis and nice
to see you again different time as well
so let me say that obviously things that
come a very long way since the crisis
and and for all of you by the way these
last couple of years have been a good
couple years to be in school as well but
there's still tremendous uncertainty
ahead of us we may have avoided the
crisis but there's a lot more work that
needs to be done when I look around the
world we're living in time of tremendous
uncertainty on an economic basis Europe
is a significant issue that bought some
time it remains an issue it's not
exactly clear what the path is and what
the destination is for that matter and
that's that is a significant pillar that
we need to get through it's costing us
about a percent percent and a half and
GDP here and around the world so this is
a significant issue to deal with there's
the US debt issue how are we going to
deal with that not till after the
elections
people ask about what's going to happen
in China this is a country that grew at
nine ten percent a year for a very long
period of time how is it going to grow
what growth rate and can they manage
that there are regulatory issues
obviously there are issues surrounding
banks but there are regulatory issues
around the world and on top of that
there are political issues you know this
is a year which in which they're going
to be 32 significant elections around
the world and 10 to 12 of them in really
major countries and these elections by
the way are influenced by the fact that
the world's really not at full
employment today not even close
if the world needed to get to full
employment today you'd need about 200
million jobs and by the way just to put
that in context over the next 10 years
the world needed to and the world does
need do and could employ everybody who
would be employable the world would need
another 400 million jobs so you're
looking at a political environment that
is rightly influenced by the fact that
no one job around the world is create
meaningful employment and work for
people and we've got a lot of work to do
on that so you put it all together
you're looking at a time of tremendous
uncertainty not only that you know you
live in a time where you get real-time
results what you're doing you know the
bond markets every morning wake up and
they tell every country what they think
about their debt I mean they tell every
company you know how safe they are the
stock market does exactly the same thing
talks about growth and I don't need
particularly this group tell you about
Twitter and everything else and you know
every morning we know exactly what
people think about us
and so the real-time feedback is a
different mechanism so whether we like
it or not we're living in a time of
volatility it's going to be with us for
a while until we figure some of these
things out and and we're all dealing
with it and we're learning to deal with
it and and frankly it's not that we're
going to have any near-term answers to
some of these uncertainties we've talked
about so that's the environment we've
got to learn to live with let me just
say one more thing I was out
at a major industrial company in in
Peoria Illinois last Wednesday great
company it's it's the soul of America
they manufacture tractors excavators etc
I won't say the name you can figure it
out
and this is a company that put a lot of
money to work almost four billion
dollars or investments and I was talking
to the management team and say you know
some days we wake up and feel really
great that's exactly what we ought to be
doing you know
maeín possibly we haven't invested
enough let's keep going and at the same
time one of the senior manager said but
there are days when I wake up in a cold
sweat did I do exactly the right thing
you know what does this mean where's the
world going to but that's the kind of
environment we're still are in and what
that means we may have stability we may
be going the right direction but there's
a lot more work to do if we want to get
back to our main goal which ought to be
to create the kind of jobs and the kind
of opportunities for young people and
people who need work and it's going to
take some time so as you think about
five ten years from now you talked about
how today there's just tremendous
uncertainty tremendous volatility what
will it take to get us to a place where
there is that stability where there will
be jobs for for all of us well look I
mean I think the Dean and I were talking
about some of these things earlier when
he he didn't know you were going to ask
that question he asked me that question
in a different way but there are some
short-term things we need to get through
we have to get through Europe we really
do and it is a it is 25 percent of the
world economy it's significant the issue
with Europe is not like they may grow
slowly but so much of the financial
system around the world and so much of
the world economies integrally tied up
with Europe that if something goes wrong
Europe is too big to fail in many ways
and so so the problem that you deal with
is a problem where you cannot
necessarily count on what this currency
is going to
look like so if you're a bank and an
Italian company wants you to make a 10
year loan usually you'd say let's figure
out what you're going to use the money
for let's go ahead and do it but there
is a moment of thought that goes through
your mind that says how do I know I'm
going to get paid back in Europe and if
it's not the euro what is it going to be
it could be the lira and and once you
start thinking about the fact that there
is so much writing on a currency union
without a fiscal union you start
thinking about boy I really need to be
safe I really need to pull back I really
need to be careful as to how I interact
with Europe and that kind of becomes a
self-fulfilling prophecy so whether we
like it or not that's front and center
and the markets are saying that it has
to be addressed there are economic
solutions to what needs to be done a lot
of them require a lot of political
strength and it's tough given the fact
there's an election in France you know
there's going to be election in Germany
next year there are lots of other
elections going on and so we're going to
have to watch this one but on a longer
term basis I think there are two things
that are really interesting to me the
first you all may or may not know this
but but I think we made a significant
dent in energy and energy availability
and I know that all of us want to look
at alternatives and we do by the way we
finance a lot of sustainable
developments alternative energy
companies as they move forward in their
journey towards creating different kind
of energy cleaner energy safer energy
but the biggest development of the world
is that in the last couple of years the
world collectively has found about two
point four trillion barrels equivalent
of energy new energy that's huge the
world consumes about thirty three
billion dollars thirty three billion
barrels of oil every year you're talking
about two point four trillion new ones
there's a lot in America as a matter of
fact forget everything right America can
become a net exporter of energy over the
next ten years there's about 200 billion
barrels of that in China talk about
supporting growth so you know when you
look out ten years if we can get through
the European situation put it in the
right place for now you're looking at an
environment where you may have the kind
of availability of energy and the kind
of cost structure on that that could
actually spur a new cycle of growth it's
very very important keep in mind in
addition to that you after that the
emerging market growth and if you can
get some of the regulatory things in the
finance area etc ironed out there is a
new cycle of infrastructure investment
that needs to be made here in the US and
certainly a lot in Africa and Asia and
Latin America by the way Brazil needs
about a trillion and a half dollars of
infrastructure investment over the next
ten years that's a huge cycle you get
that right that can create a lot of jobs
as well as create the kind of growth the
world needs so I'd look to a newly found
positive perspective and energy I'd look
to the world getting together trying to
figure out how to finance its
infrastructure over the next ten years
I'd looked a merging market growth and
the consumer they're growing very well
and I'd looked at rate and global
capital flows is the four big drivers
ultimately the solution out of this
uncertainty has to be growth there's no
way no other way to create those jobs
other than creating this growth and so I
think things are coming together it's
going to take a lot of political will
we're going to have to get through these
32 elections find out what these
governments and philosophies are going
to be like but there is a real
possibility we can get this right on
them coming together and solving these
problems it's interesting to use that
phrase especially during this time it
seems like especially with the banks
there's a lot of criticism right the
narrative is essentially banks caused
the crisis and government bailed out the
banks so how do you respond to this
narrative that's almost developed
becoming part of US history now that how
do you respond to this criticism look I
think the first place to do is you gotta
start by acknowledging that the
financial system has lost trust and
credibility with people out there and
this you know it's it's as as plain as
night and day and that and that a lot of
that was because the financial system
and it's not only banks by the way
there's a huge shadow banking system
there lots of different aspects of
Finance but the banking system somehow
swerved to some extent away from serving
clients and serving the real economy
which is what the intent is towards
serving itself and and and you know it
has caused a lot of hardships for a lot
of people as we witness from what's
happening here in the US but also what
from witness what's happening in in
Europe and I think that's an important
part of the narrative and starts with
acknowledging that that's really what
happened you take a look at a company
like ours well what are we doing well
when I came in to the to this position
and and and the deans made it really
extremely clear I do not get any award
for market timing but as I came in you
know I had to start looking at
everything so are we in the right
businesses why are we doing what we're
doing what should we be and it became
very clear that we needed to return to
the basics of banking as a bank and we
decided to sell 40% of the companies and
40% of the assets that we held and we're
actually the only large bank that has
shrunk in size as a result of that we're
three quarters of the way through that
we got another 10% to go but our core
decision as a bank was return to the
basics of banking figure out what you're
good at
we're in 160 countries we financed
global trade global capital flows serve
IBM serve Exxon serve Google serve
Apple's serve everybody around the world
because they have offices around the
world and not only that there are
imports and exports going on focus on
what you're good at get back to the
basics of what you're good at and get
out of those things that are peripheral
not important to the business that was a
critical critical decision in addition
to that we set out some very clear
criteria and principles for what we do
and how we do it in them and other than
the obvious which should be we are here
to serve the real economy we're here to
serve clients I call it common purpose
we have the same purpose with our
clients we have same purpose with each
other the most important pillar of that
to me is practicing responsible finance
and I tell all my people in the company
before you engage with a client before
you do a transaction ask yourself three
questions ask yourself whether it's
right for your client ask yourself
whether it adds any economic value and
ask yourself if it is right for the
system or responsible to the system as a
whole in the answer and all three must
be yes and only then you should proceed
that's what banking has been about and
that's what we've been about for 200
years I mean we got founded in 1812 as a
bank in when a bunch of merchants came
together in New York they needed to
finance New York Liverpool trade there's
no other place they could get that that
kind of financing and and since then
some of you might have seen some of the
ads were running but we've been
literally connecting the world financing
some of the most transformative projects
in the world the Panama Canal the trans
static cable you know the jumbo jet I
mean you know the list goes on and on
that's what we're supposed to be doing
and if you get back to doing what you're
supposed to be doing and you practice
responsible finance you get to restoring
trust and credibility it's not going to
happen through apps it's going to happen
by doing the right thing the world is
going to look back and say this is the
financial system that truly serves us
and it's truly serving the real economy
what one more comment that's important I
do know that we're big as a bank and
there are other banks that have gotten
big the most important thing in business
is and you all are going to know this
you you need to be sized appropriately
for the task at hand we're only as big
as our clients need to be and there was
a
big part of our redesign as a company
now unfortunately part of that meant we
had to go from three and 75,000 people
to 260,000 people as a company we're
completely focused on those businesses
that are really important to our clients
but that's the narrow and I think that's
the narrative that's really going to be
important for the financial system to be
on you see me I spent a lot of time
thinking about finance and um and I like
to switch gears and talk about your
background and your career in finance
you've been a professor a finance
professor an investment banker a trader
you started a hedge fund and now you're
CEO of a Wall Street firm so I get the
sense you like finance why you know I
did - you take I can't hold a job what
can I tell ya that's not where I started
I mean I growing up culture has a lot to
do with it and what you are expected to
do is sometimes driven by by what people
think you ought to be and so when I was
growing up in India you know you either
had to be a doctor an engineer so I said
okay fine I'll be an engineer and I
started there and and and it was good I
mean I enjoyed it never any good at it I
thought so I said well you know maybe
I'll be a good banker what do you know
all right so but I I went from
engineering and I went into business
school I had really enjoyed that I
really enjoyed economics but and and
you're right
I mean I really enjoy the subject of
markets and how decisions get made how
it's real time public policy economic
policy these are all exciting yet you
know finding exactly what to do with
that you know was not easy i I you know
started off believing and thinking I
would like being in academics and a
teacher I do like that but I write I
like real world problems more and
and you know it all came together when
when when I wound up going to Morgan
Stanley Morgan Stanley back then was
about 2500 people and it was it was the
size of some of the smaller private
equity funds today in some ways it was a
different era it's almost 30 years ago
and that was really enjoyable because I
had a lot of ability to do things I
wanted to do and and and I grew up
through that and and I've never really
talked back as to how I got from here to
here to here lots of interesting
incidents that happen along the way that
they guide you but I do enjoy the topic
and you got to do that I mean if you're
not passionate about learning if you're
not passionate about what you're doing
you don't like the subject matter yeah
might as well go do something else and
that's that's a critical aspect of what
makes one successful you just mentioned
that there were a lot of incidents that
made you you know make different
decisions could you share with us well
as all of us in this room are trying to
figure out what to do when we grow up
how did you go about making those
decisions what are some icky inflection
points yeah first of all don't try to
grow up too soon and too fast I got to
tell you that you know don't don't don't
underestimate the the benefit of youth
and what you got and and the opportunity
is that that gives you you know I really
never tried to manage my career I never
thought about the future in that way I
mean if you if you you you couldn't
write a novel collecting the connecting
the dots of my career and say you're
something that could have been planned
ever so it never happened that way to me
the most important thing I learned was
from one of my teachers one of her
professors said look there are very
simple rules just figure out what you're
really passionate about and follow that
just do that secondly you know if you
happen to be passionate about something
that's a growth industry that's great by
the way that's that's what you should
really try and see if you can get
passionate about that and and lastly you
know if you are gonna go out and do
something make sure you do it with a
company or people that have the right
values and that you really like working
with it and that's it and and and I
thought I did that I mean that's how I
picked the places I went
who I worked with and who I worked for
as well and never really managed my
career along the way you know one thing
led to the other led to the other led to
the other when I left academia to go to
Morgan Stanley that was a point in time
that there were a number of people who
are finance professors or economics
professors the left academia to go into
into business you know I'm not saying
that I compare anywhere close to him but
Fisher black left at that point MIT to
go into business Steven keel Hoffer I'm
their whole host of people who had left
academia and and so it seemed just right
because the real world problems were
there and in corporate finance in
capital markets there were no real
futures markets back then the options
markets were new derivatives was a was a
concept in textbooks I mean these were
all sort of interesting times and that's
that's how I got there and the industry
grew I grow with it and and you know I
think the most important benefit to me
was that I found myself at a place which
was a real meritocracy I mean you're
talking about investment banking back in
1982-83 you know how shall I say it was
not exactly the bastion of diversity
back then and to find a somebody who was
born in India Grob become an engineer
get a PhD of all the things wind up at
Morgan Stanley and and wind up becoming
president it says a lot more about the
company I was awed than it says about me
right that that was the environment that
allowed it to happen and to me it really
was about having an environment true
meritocracy where learning was rewarded
performance was rewarded and that if you
did better you got ahead better and
that's really what happened that the
most important decision I had to make in
my career the most important decision I
had to make was to go from and being an
individual producer somebody who was
really good at something and really
enjoyed doing it to somebody who decided
that actually you know what I could
enjoy becoming a man
it's very different to be good at what
you're doing it's completely different
thing to say now I'm going to get my
enjoyment by watching others succeed
that transition is a very very difficult
transition to make and and you know it's
one of those things where you have to
teach yourself that you go from being
the valedictorian to somebody who
manages valedictorians and there are
plenty of them here I know and how you
manage that talent how you nurture the
talent how you grow it was a very big
shift and that's probably the single
biggest shift that got me from what I
was a financial professional or somebody
who really enjoyed that to where I am
today I am that reminded me of something
I read in your background I'd read an
interview with your father in September
of o8 and he said the day Europe he
didn't know that was going to be public
my dad is now let me see my dad is 89
years old and he's still well forget
about him I don't understand Twitter so
you know again anyway go ahead sir
he um he said the day you're appointed
CEO of Citi the first thing you did when
you got home was to call him and move by
to share the good news with him and and
in that interview he talked about how he
was so proud of your humility given all
of these career you know just
accomplishments you had made had reached
over the last ten years and and that he
was also proud of the conference you
were as you stare down the abyss in the
crisis and so I it made me very curious
about your upbringing when you think
about sort of the 16 years in India and
growing up in New York sort of what what
in your background prepared you for the
crisis well you know I but I didn't I'm
not so sure I called him to share the
good news at least I called him to get a
lot of support I know that and he's
always been supportive and look I mean
it's it's very hard to piece all of this
together every bit of everything that
I've done has been a learning experience
along the way and you know you sort of
you learn a few things
once you become a manager or you try to
become a manager leader it becomes very
obvious you know you're not a leader
unless you got followers right I mean if
people are not willing to follow you
doesn't matter what else what else you
learn or think about and so the the
simple the simple sort of truths that
like and somebody said that in your
video that you showed earlier is true I
think is John Doerr you know it's it's
trust and integrity are the number one
things and so if you have the values
that go with always making sure you're
trusted as somebody is honest and says
the right things does the right thing
that's a critical thing and that's the
number one attribute of a good leader
the second attribute is a leader who
understands that the team where the team
needs to feel the leader is looking
after the team and thinking about what's
the best for the team well that's part
of the community that's how we grew up
in India it's part of being part of the
family it's really important you know
you need functional skills of course you
do you got to be good at what you do you
need to be able to know how to make
decisions and a lot of experience helps
with that by the way the more experience
you have the better decision maker you
are it's as simple as that you don't
grow up you don't you're not necessary
born with that you can learn it and you
grow with it I think that becomes a very
critical part of what you do because
that really drives judgment in many ways
and judgments sort of accumulation of
all the skills you learned over the
years I think the the ability to
communicate is critical I mean you
cannot underestimate the need people
have to know what's going on and why
you're doing what you're doing why are
you going in a particular direction and
as much as you think communication is
important think again it's probably the
most important thing you can do as a
leader and I think the last part is in
there you know you talk about that
they talk about what my dad said
the line that always stuck with me was
the line that John F Kennedy used which
is that civility is not a sign of
weakness and so humility is a big part
of what you learn and believe me when
you trade you learn humility when you
run a hedge fund you learn humility and
and and so do to lead with humility is
is really what makes for people rallying
around what you want to get done so I
can't tell you exactly what happened
where where where I learned some of
these things or some of these things
that that were part of my upbringing but
but ultimately it's sort of the the
culmination and the cumulative aspects
everything I've gotten done over the
years that brought me here thank you for
sharing with us your values um that fast
wanting to sort of this point in time
one question at every GSB student in
this room has had to answer is what
matters most to you and why it's a
question in our application and so we
spend dozens of hours thinking about it
and wrestling over it and so I know you
have about 15 seconds to think about it
but what matters most most to you and
why well so god that's a tough question
we know we all know soon we saw your
answer I'll keep them for future
reference ah well look um you know I
come at everything I do with a sense of
responsibility and I have a
responsibility for towards my two kids
making sure they get the right kind of
education the right kind of background I
keep I get the same sense for City which
I'm running I feel a sense of
responsibility for the 260,000 people
that are with the city I feel a response
and responsibility for for the the
clients of the company I feel
responsibility for for Columbia
University on the Board of Trustees
sorry about that but it's sad it is a
responsibility I have so what matters
most to me is that is that I not only
take those responsibilities I
seriously and I do the best I can but
the world looks at what I've done and
say you know what he tried to do the
best he can to fulfill those
responsibilities to the best of his
capabilities that really matters to me
you just touched on your two kids and I
have one final questions before we open
up to the audience but um but as you
think of the world your children will
grow up in there a few years younger
than I think most of us in this room as
you think about the future world that
they will lead and as you sort of look
at this room of future entrepreneurs and
future business leaders and folks will
lead nonprofits what are some of the two
three four or five key life lessons you
want to impart to the next generation of
business leaders well look I think to me
the most important thing is you cannot
succeed unless you're doing something
you're passionate about that is the key
lesson to me I mean it's it is
absolutely critical your success your
your greatness comes from that and so I
tell my two kids you got to find your
passion and they're young you know one
of them just started University they're
the ones still in high school and and
they're searching and it's okay I mean
you gotta keep searching and I took me a
while to get to what I thought I liked
so that's the most important thing
figure out what it is you really like
and I don't really mind what it is I
mean frankly it's not my thing it's
their thing they gotta figure out what
they like and follow that I think that's
really important the second thing I
would impart to them is make sure you
appreciate understand the importance of
your social relationships and the trust
that is really implied in those and what
it means to to be part of those social
relationships and some people think
about this as citizenship yeah you can
talk about it that way but really is
about about you live in a community
right and you live with your friends and
what does that mean how should you
behave I think that's that's that's to
me the second most important thing it's
really important and then you know I
think I stop right there in terms of
those two things I think are absolutely
critical to me I hope we
everything we can we can to impart them
the best values I know that if they're
passionate enough and they have the
right social relationship the right sort
of human relationships they can carry on
they can be successful at they want to
be I think they're fortunate lucky to be
second generation Americans we're
first-generation Americans having come
here I mean there's no other country
that I know of that can provide young
people with the kind of entrepreneurship
capabilities that this country can not
one not anywhere for the 160 countries
that I've been to there is something so
unique about what's happening in America
and what America is all about that I'm
absolutely sure that if they just stick
to passion stick to minding their
relationships and and in human
interactions and the last parts are
really important is nobody got anywhere
without a lot of hard work and so if
they do that they're going to be fine
thank you very much now we'd like to
open up to questions from the audience
there's going to be a few folks walk
around with mics so please raise your
hand and then somebody will come and
find you get one up here
hi my name is Sal I'm a master student
in the management science department so
as a leader how did you go about
streamlining your company from three
thousand seven three hundred and seventy
thousand people employees to 260 without
disturbing the employee motivation and
company culture so that it does not
affect Citigroup's
future progress yeah and that's a great
question it's very important questions
so to me streamlining comes in a variety
of different forms and let me tell you
how we did it the first thing is as I
said we decided what business are we in
what should we be in and those other
businesses that that we didn't think we
should be in or I didn't think we should
be in we're businesses that we really
nurtured as well we made sure that
people understood very clearly that that
these were important businesses we
created the right incentive structures
for our people in there and the point
was if City is not the home that doesn't
mean there aren't other great homes for
a business of this sort and that
actually worked very well and a good
part of our 375 donors 260 came from
that those actions where we did sell
business in a very steady methodical way
to other people some of them we took
public and some of them were were sold
to to other people in the financial
services businesses and the other part
of this is we also went inside the
organization and we started looking at
okay are there actions or things that
we're doing we shouldn't be doing for
ourselves and so we found a lot of
things we're doing on the processing
side and we put them all together and
say okay let's create a company around
us let's create a company around these
activities actually we're not that great
at doing these are good activities we
took some of those and we actually sold
them to other people or we passed on
those activities so we sold some to
Wipro to Tata Consultancy etc companies
of that sort who took big areas of what
we did and took them with them and and
that also counted for a lot of what
what we used to do the third part of
what we had to do is have some very
strong thoughtful outplacement programs
and they anything you had to do you had
to do on the basis of merits who was
good whether we needed them or not and
we went through that in a very
methodical way including providing
people help to find jobs somewhere else
we were helped by the fact that we were
really early on in our restructuring
when I came in while the crisis was was
beginning starting you know you didn't
have the crescendo so to say so we
started early on and that really helped
a lot of the activities that we did
along that time the most difficult thing
culturally is to come out publicly and
say 40 percent of your businesses
non-core okay and that is a incredibly
difficult step to take and we had to
weigh a lot of different ways of going
so are we going to say nothing and just
sell something here something there some
here some there and then the markets
will start saying hey wait a minute
where are you going where are you going
to stop and if we did that that could
destabilize everybody inside the
organization so the big decision we made
was saying sixty percent of the company
was core and that core business had a
certain culture we wanted a certain
direction the company had to take
certain businesses we were in as certain
types of clients we were going to serve
in certain principles we were going to
follow that became on the other side a
rallying cry for everybody else to say
hey this is the future this is where
we're going and of course we had to do
exactly what you said manage the other
40% and I've talked about that yeah
I'm mr.panda thank you for being here
with us today I'm Felix Bernstein first
year and be a student quick question for
you you know you mentioned that you're
now back to the basics and focusing on
the core business and I guess I'm
curious to know what systems are you
putting in place as the pendulum swings
and you know you don't try to dance as
the music sort of begins to play thank
you
well I don't dance
that's music or not wouldn't make a
difference but the most important point
is a point you're making so what is the
big difference at City the big
difference let me talk a little bit
about the trends we see okay going on
around the world one we think they're
going to be 150 cities around the world
they're going to be 50% of the GDP of
the world in the next do two and a half
three decades and we're today in about
120 of those cities now what's
interesting about those cities and I've
talked to publishers and people of that
sort the 18 year old in those cities
like 18 year old South Paulo has a lot
more in common with 18 year old and
Moscow then they may have with their
parents in those cities
so the interconnectedness the mode of
thinking and how the 150 cities think is
an incredible shift that's ahead of us
it's in addition to organization it's
sort of homogenize a ssin in in in
intellectual direction and so we've got
to stop thinking about countries in our
business we need to start thinking about
those 150 cities they could all be in
the US or they could be around the world
and so big change for us is looking at
our consumer business and not having the
systems being one for us one for UK one
for Russia one for Brazil but we're
going completely global it's the same
consumer banking system around the world
which means that you can be a customer
anywhere in the world you walk into any
city bank anywhere else in the world
you'll be recognized people know who you
are
what you have what you need not only
that related to that you know where the
world's going it's going to have to be
banking anywhere anyhow any device any
mode and so the big shift systems wise
at Citi is we're going completely global
unified systems around the world to
serve the consumer the other big trend
is global trade global capital flows and
as much as we think that it's all about
the developed markets trading with
emerging markets the big shift is Brazil
to India India to China
Africa to Brazil South South flows
connecting those pipes to make sure we
can enter mediate money that flows
around the world and trade that gets
financed around the world that's also
the same institutional system around the
world so that's another system that's
there those are the rails on which we
move money every day by the way we're up
to about on average three trillion
dollars of cash we move around the world
every day and just about everything the
US government does around the world has
done through our pipes the u.s. embassy
banking system those kind of things so
that's sort of the integration aspect of
the systems we're designing it's one
company just happens to be in 150
locations the last point I'll stop there
is data I don't need to tell this group
what data means you all know exactly the
power of data we have more data than
almost any other private company in the
world because we're 160 countries we
know consumer data we need institutional
data we know flow data we need trade we
know trading data it's incredible the
amount of information we have and so the
biggest thing we're doing in my view is
redoing our data management architecture
to take these multiple petabytes of data
we have and translate that into
information and content for our clients
to help them make better decisions so
the as we look forward and we look to
the trends around the world you know our
business hangs on a technological
chassis and that technological chassis
is one chassis around the world it's not
only based on hardware systems and other
architecture but based on the same
customer facing architecture around the
world and the same data architecture
around the world that's a lot of work
and a lot of money and for city that's
taking a company that used to be this
way siloed around the world to shifting
it horizontally completely and of course
you can imagine we are
therefore a dream client of just about
anybody in this valley at this point I'm
a recent alum and I won't know what your
response to dealing or coping with
failure would be my response to dealing
killing the failure well it's it's so so
I can I can look back and think about
what did I do
right because nobody ever has gone up or
done what they've done in a straight
line it's always been on the basis of a
number of setbacks and we and I have had
many in the process you know I think the
the there is obviously the emotional
aspect of failure and then there's a
rational aspect of failure you know
you've got to cope through the emotional
aspect of failure I can't tell you how I
mean it's it's related to families it's
related to your support system it's
related to your friends it's related to
finding strength somewhere to get
through it
and I think it's important I mean do not
ever minimize that aspect
doesn't matter how rational you are
you're not going to be able to cope with
with failure unless you get over the
emotional side because what you got to
do there is you need to get yourself
fortified to say I really want to figure
out what went wrong and to figure out
what went wrong to learn from it to say
ok I'm going to go try again I'm going
to try somewhere else I'm going to go to
a different place but what can I learn
from what I did where can I get help how
do I get myself those skills to allow me
to succeed and I think that's that's
sort of the natural step and and in my
own way the second stage takes time the
first stage is the stage you need to get
over and and and believe me I mean we
get a lot of positive negative feedback
every day but but coping with the coping
with the with the
the scope of failure is something that
has to be done emotionally first all
right we have time for one more question
I think hi my name is Andy and I'm a
second-year here at Stanford you
mentioned that cities taking like a
large stake in sustainable energy and
kind of green energy and I was curious
what do you see as like the most viable
in the next ten years in the next 15
years the most viable kind of energy you
guys are investing in and going along
with that with rising gas prices and
kind of more green vehicles what do you
see as the future of electric
automobiles in not only the US but
internationally yeah I mean I think I
think those are those are all important
questions and it's a it's those are
questions for which we're all going to
need answers not in the context of what
each one each one of us thinks
individually but also in the context a
lot of these relate to collective
decision-making because because you need
systems set up you've got gas comes
pumps everywhere around the country well
what's going to be the alternative so
there's a lot of work that needs to be
done there so look I mean I think I
think there are there are a couple of
very interesting things that are
happening one is natural gas now I
understand it's a fossil fuel right now
it comes from down there very clearly
but it is clean energy and we're running
at two dollars a cubic feet a foot right
now which is incredible I mean it is a
vastly different price point than
everything else and we've got a lot of
that in the US as a matter of fact
enough not only here by the way there's
a lot in Israel there's a lot in the
Mediterranean ocean there's a lot in
China etc so I would I would look to
having looking at natural gas having a
major role to play in terms of the next
decade a couple of decades in in the
energy future including by the way
having the freight fleet in the u.s. go
to natural gas as a powering source
versus gasoline and diesel which is what
they're using right now the people I
talk to companies I talk to hear
investing very few of them are going to
diesel very few
than going to oil very few of them are
going to gasoline they're almost all
going towards natural gas that's a
significant significant shift in my view
clean because of the source of the
energy but an important one I think the
second big shift is this debate over you
know water cars going to get powered by
and and you know I think that there's
still a debate going on there lots of
models in terms of where vehicles go now
the electric car sounds extremely
appealing because you can shift from
hydroelectric to gas to oil to coal or
whatever you want to the back end solar
energy as long as there's electricity
you don't need to change the
infrastructure if it is electric so it's
a very very appealing concept and our
guys have done a lot of work on it as a
matter of fact not only us but obviously
the auto companies have and Ed Morse who
who does a lot of writing for us has put
out in wonderful reply think was last
week a couple of weeks ago and all this
stuff but there are lots of differences
even in models in electric cars some of
them are you plug and you get charged up
and you travel and there are other
models there's company called a better
place and it's an Israeli company and
what they do is they say that we're in
the business of having you shift out
your battery into new one 45 seconds if
you want a new source of energy it's a
different model what it says is you
don't necessarily have to only plug in
your car to charge but your new gas
stations are battery changing stations
you go in there and the same time it
takes you to fill up a gas tank you take
the battery out and replace it you're on
your way again but that requires a grid
it requires changing stations it
requires a lot of infrastructure to it
so I think the the changes in battery
technology which which is actually
accelerating a pretty good phase
together with economic models like the
better place model could actually create
a real future for electric cars so you
may find a bifurcated market you may
find Freight running on natural gas you
could find commuting
happening on electric cars I mean that's
a real possibility for the future but
it's in play I mean this is happening
now and you know the you guys are too
young to know this but beta versus VHS
you know you could have a better product
versus inferior product but one is
adopted or the typewriter example of how
QD becomes the becomes the the scale so
we're at that stage where it would be
helpful to have a lot more thinking on
national basis of where should we be
going but some of these standards may be
set for us going forward but I'm
actually very very excited and very
encouraged by the entire energy area
it's one of those areas a good fortune
that we haven't been counting on I'm not
so sure the markets are completely
discounted this yet either but it's
going to be one thing that may turn out
to be a positive for all of us over the
next 10 years looks like we're at a time
I wanted to thank you very much for
being just so open and sharing your
insight you've not only encouraged me to
really identify my passions but also to
to buy some more city shares thank you
that's right
change wives gotta meet under lives
change organizations guy [ __ ] change
organizations and open eyes I might
change the world